Moitai Muay Thai,
Thai boxing,
even it,
that is the only time I've never heard of that.
Nope.
You're so,
you're so,
uh,
what are you white?
Yeah,
you're white.
You're also like a,
a non jock.
Well,
I was a jock my whole life.
What,
what'd you do?
I played a football.
Oh,
that's right.
I really feel 12 forever and tracking a bunch of stuff.
Then you fuck with,
then I stopped.
Did you fucking body up at all?
Uh,
no.
Not too bad.
My shoulders a little bit.
My shoulder's a little,
but uh,
that's pretty much it.
My,
my knees,
you know,
like I run a lot now.
I've been running all that for the last couple of months and uh,
on,
I just want to be in better shape when they feel better.
I dropped like burn off,
say 15 pounds.
Yeah,
exactly.
I was like,
maybe,
maybe.
Yeah.
Your face looks thinner,
man.
Yeah,
it looks good.
You have drafted a bunch.
That's awesome.
Thanks man.
Yeah,
it's a cool thing once you get going,
right?
Yeah.
Get that momentum.
That's what's up.
Well,
you know,
it's really was up was I was kind of cruising along and just like lost five
pounds and just kinda like hanging around.
And then I realized I'm working out like this workout that I'm doing is,
we've been a warm up when I was an athlete,
like this wouldn't even have been a warm up.
And I'm like,
oh,
that was pretty good.
And I was like,
I have to stop being a sissy and try and really push it a little more.
Just get a trainer,
Eh,
I don't like intimacy.
Oh,
that's real.
Well you know what else you can do?
There's actually apps where you can follow an app and the APP will put you
through a workout.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Several of them now.
They're really good.
Oh cool.
A bunch of really good ones.
I don't have any affiliation with any of them,
so got not naming any of them,
but yeah,
you can.
Um,
you can even get a yoga one.
You get a 90 minute yoga one and just do yoga and it talks you through the
poses.
It's great.
Yeah.
I used to do yoga all the time,
but I feel like I've got to,
uh,
I feel I have to shift it into lifting weights again.
Like,
cause I've just been dropping now,
but I just feel like,
you know,
a little bit.
I don't want to be,
yeah.
I don't want,
I don't want to be the guy like at the pool with no arms.
You know what I mean?
So many people have motivated themselves by going to the beach or the pool with
very little clothes on,
like thought about fuck summertime.
Fuck.
People are going to know.
Yeah,
exactly.
I reveal my secrets.
People going to know what disgusts me about,
yeah.
This is my glove.
Look at it.
This is my laziness.
Luck.
This is what I did all entire,
this is my poor food choices right here.
Look it.
This is drinking upper,
the upper part.
Yeah.
This is the part,
right on the sides.
But I really just,
but then when I started getting after and being like,
don't be such a sissy,
like workout,
try and push it.
Then you want it.
Then I wanted to do it more.
Then I got into it.
Then I'm like,
all right,
let's go.
Now I'm going further and going quicker.
But uh,
this is all been cardio.
All Cardio.
What about just body weight stuff?
Like you know,
I mean it's not a bad idea to start it off with body weight.
First of all.
Pushups.
Yeah,
because you haven't really done much like that in awhile.
Yeah.
It's Chin ups,
push ups in the body.
Weight squats really don't need much else.
Really.
No really.
I've been doing more pushups.
Depends a ferocious workout in with change,
grip pushups,
Chin ups,
body weight squats.
Just to just those things.
Does that mean I have to get them of those Chin up bars?
It goes in the doorway.
Yeah.
Get a real one though.
Cause those things fall on.
People don't,
the ones that hang folks listen to me.
Yeah.
Those ones that hang on the door,
the door Jamb,
I used to work construction.
Those fucking things are not designed for you hanging on.
Now you have little tiny nails and that's the one that people like me probably
installed them and sometimes you don't hit a stud.
You see that little tiny nail is going right into the fucking dry wall and
you're hanging that thing over there and it's pulling on that sucker.
Messed my shoulder up.
I'll be best that fuckers that drill into the side of the door.
You know what I'm saying?
The ones that they go right in the side.
They screw it this way.
Go into the four screws on each side.
That'll hold your weight.
All right.
That'll hold your way.
I'll get that.
That one work,
cause it's put,
you're pulling down on the wood to the way those things are.
It's like sitting on the wood.
You know those ones that hopefully the top of the door.
Yeah.
Shit is a recipe for a broken neck.
I feel like that thing was in like every eighties movie.
Yeah.
I mean I'm sure they have good ones that do that.
I'm sure that,
yeah,
sure.
But you should really check out your fucking moldings first.
Just moldings a pull and I just lay on the ground and do some pushups.
Yeah,
but real chin up bar man.
A real chin up bar is made.
If you just got one in,
in a park,
just go to the fucking park.
It's your outside.
They'll a lot of parks have like those,
yeah.
Bars.
A little setups.
We could do counseling.
Yeah.
Nobody knows joke.
How many tools are great for working out.
I know.
They seem too simple.
They seem like,
oh ladies west go over there.
I go to Nautilus.
I don't need this.
Right,
exactly.
I do my leg extensions on Norell's.
I got my membership.
I use once a month.
Bodyweight Squat seem easy when you do three.
Yeah.
But when you do a hundred and become very fucking hard,
right?
When you get to like 70 and you're like,
Whoa,
shit in rid of that burn baby.
And you start counting down in tents.
And I remember doing pushups when we played football and you would do,
you know,
200 who will be like 200 and break them on a row,
no break coming up doing a row.
They would,
we do like 30 and then split them up and uh,
you know,
there was a big time workout and now I'm doing like 25.
I'm like,
I'm good for a couple of days.
Sorry man.
It is getting anywhere more than 30 pushups.
It's like woo.
Shit starts getting crazy.
Yeah.
It was a lot of pushing.
To like your body has to be conditioned for that and if it's not,
it lets you know you're like dirty arms start shaking.
The funniest part is hockey.
Around 19 though,
you get to like 1819 like,
Bro,
I'm feeling fucking smooth.
It's so funny.
Whatever number you have in your head is where you start to,
right?
If you say I'm doing 20 you start shaking at 18 if you say I'm doing 25 you
don't start shaking until 23 you know,
it's a real mental thing.